to even multiple you know doctors as
well get get a second opinion uh but as
much as you can to gather as much cash
as possible in time for the surgery is
going to be your goal thanks Annette for
calling I'm so sorry going through it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
gazelle was made for you the never
quitting non-stopping gazelle intents
with gazelle you can say goodbye to
monthly fees and experience a seamless
integration with every dollar so no
matter how or where you spend you are
always in control and since gazelle is
FDIC insured you don't have to worry if
your money is safe
gazelle the debit card that helps you
spend and save the Ramsay way
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I told
George in the break I was like let's
revisit that because I feel like we gave
Annette's in our last segment quick
advice with the situation so she has
about forty thousand dollars in debt
she's even struggling just to make you
know make payments right now on even
just getting food and then has an
upcoming surgery uh to fix her eyes so
that her her cornea something with her
cornea so it's her site it's a big deal
um so what we were what we were saying
is that a lot of you know some of the
angst is coming from the unknown not
knowing what insurance is going to pay
and also getting a second opinion and
then you know having multiple opinions
is very important especially if you're
going to do something like a surgery
because it depending on the doctor the
hospital I mean all of it can it could
vary drastically and so that's an
important piece of information but
always you guys if you're in a situation
that you have to pause that snowball
and say okay you know whether it's a
medical procedure whether it's you know
you're going to be moving in the next 90
days like we need to pile up some cash
whether it's you know again medical
you're you're pregnant you know whatever
it is and there's reasons to pause the
debt snowball for a period of time
to save up cash for something we
recommend doing that and so for in her
case as well you know understanding how
to get some extra income because she
makes forty three thousand dollars a
year uh getting that extra income is
going to be really important to pile up
that cash and then in the medical
community too it's like okay you know is
there is there a payment plan option to
set yourself up in you know so so kind
of talking through some of those options
and looking at hard numbers not just the
emotion is is also very important yeah
and there was a few things she mentioned
there she had followed the plan and it
worked and then she fell off the horse
and went back into a bunch of credit
card debt around Christmas time and now
there was a lot of Shame and guilt and
baggage along with that that we didn't
really even have time to address
but part of that it when we took a
similar call the other week where
someone did they did their debt-free
Scream and then went back into debt
later which is fairly rare I will say
but part of that was if you cut up that
car to net then you can't go into debt
and so part of it is getting rid of the
things that caused you to cause harm to
you in the first place so where you go
you know what I need to talk to family
and say I can't do gifts this year I
don't have the money and I don't want to
put myself in a situation where I'm in
my mental health is struggling my
Financial Health is struggling because
you got to open a present that's right
oh my gosh like it's yeah this Christmas
season you guys we're on like the thick
of starting to shop for it and just be
aware I'm like you know if you if you're
not in a position to give a ton this
year and buy gifts and everything
communicate that and and say it out loud
because it removes a lot of that like
all that fear of what are they thinking
what's the story in my head that I'm
telling myself about what's all your
pride yeah and and just say hey this
year this is the situation because being
generous with Christmas gifts to friends
and family and going into debt for that
is not worth the burden of the after
effects of what ends up happening uh in
January February March April and so on
so yeah you're exactly right George of
just taking the Temptation out cutting
up the cards and knowing that yes your
behavior is what has to change in order
for you to make progress and so I hate
that for her because you know she's in
it she's in a tough situation but also
don't beat yourself up if you have to
pause the debt snowball because life
happened that's right it's okay yes we
want you to be gazelle intense and
that's awesome but John deloney and I we
took a call in the show the other day
and she said hey my mental health is
like on the brink and I'm trying to pay
off dead and we said pause the dead
snowball and make sure that you're
healthy and then we can get back to the
debt yes it'll still be there to pay off
and you can get back to gazelle
intensity but we've got to take care of
ourselves and our health as well yeah
it's not just like straight linear line
going up at all it's like it's up and
down you guys you want to be on the on
the path of going up right uh of of
getting yourself in a better financial
situation Health scares man that is one
of those I've had it never again moments
when you deal with something like that
and you don't have the money you're not
sure how you're going to pay for this
and it's it literally I mean this is one
of those life or death things and so and
Healthcare as we know it it's it's just
a crab show Rachel it's like going to a
restaurant and there's no pricing on the
menu and I don't know what this is going
to cost and so I don't want to go
through with it and there's lack of
transparency and we need a lot of reform
in that area for sure yes you're exactly
right all right up next we have Andrew
in is it marquette's sounds right is
that right okay hey Andrew welcome to
the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
so I'm in the early stages of
potentially getting a new job and moving
I'm kind of in the early interview
stages so nothing's set in stone yet but
if we move currently we live in a home
uh where it's 100 paid off we're debt
free
um and where we're moving to the housing
prices are a lot higher so our current
house would probably sell
maybe 120 130.
um after we finish a couple of the
projects I haven't finished yet and then
uh where we're going that would not be
enough to pay cash for a house so I was
kind of wondering what the best option
would be would it be to
maybe one thing you thought about was
buy some land for cash and then rent for
a few years and cash flow building a
house or would it be better to just
use our what we get from our current
house as a down payment on something in
the new location yeah where are you guys
moving to
I actually did on your necklace like the
Nashville area oh okay so from Michigan
to Tennessee that's quite the hall
yeah so I I would recommend Andrew
honestly
um since we're talking about where we
are right now which is great I would
rent when you guys first get here don't
I would not feel the pressure to go and
buy because like every city out there
there's parts of it that are awesome and
great for your family there's Parts
they're like oh that's where all the 20
the gen's ears are that's great they
don't have a yard and I wish we did or
that that side is more artsy this one's
way too small to go to these schools
yeah or the schools yeah I mean it's all
of it and so I really I would not make a
big financial decision like buying a
house
um until you really really really know
the area and so yeah if I were you I
mean I would probably just rent for a
year uh and see where you're at and then
yes take the money from the sale of your
home the 130 and use it uh yeah for a
down payment and then I would just take
the formula that we always say around
here when it comes to buying a home for
your new mortgage should be a 15-year
fixed rate no more than 25 of your
take-home pay is your monthly payment
and kind of Follow that rule of thumb
and and then and then buy something with
that yeah and the question to always ask
yourself is would I buy a house in
Marquette Michigan for 130 000 if I
lived in Nashville and the answer is
usually no I probably wouldn't do that
and that's how you know the answer is
okay I'm gonna sell it I'm going to put
the money I get from the proceeds in a
high yield savings account we're going
to rent for a year while we stack up
more cash and then when we're ready we
do the down payment
so that's the way to do it with wisdom
and patience where you don't have any
regrets
sure so you guys think the like the land
option would just not be smart I mean
you know I mean in Tennessee land is I
mean it's expensive or you're saying in
Marquette
no no in in Tennessee so the reason the
reason I like that idea I'll be I'll be
perfectly honest is I really like the
hunt and so getting some land would be
nice to be able to hunt on but I do
understand that land I don't I haven't
really done like super detailed research
so I don't know what the language yeah
so yeah I mean at that I mean that's an
option I wouldn't be mad at that if
there's land that you guys could afford
to buy and then yeah and then you rent
take out a construction loan do the you
know build the house uh that you guys
want but again it's all going to be
about your budget and depending on kind
of where you are and yeah we hear a lot
of guys here that love to hunt and I'm
sure they'd all would love to buy some
land but some of them just they go out
and hunt and they live in normal
neighborhoods and they go hunt on the
weekends and so that's a very normal
thing as well so I love the dream but it
just may be a five to ten year dream
versus a one-year dream yes yeah but
we're not mad at yeah buying a piece of
land and building on it he finds him
some land he does he just wants to have
20 acres of nothing around him and so
you know that's there's doesn't every
guy though see George my husband what he
would move so he would move out of a
neighborhood in an instant and just be
on just Bland with trees I also like
Civilization and being near a grocery
store you know there's some conveniences
to that as well
you're a metropolitan man I'm a city
slicker Rachel that's right from Boston
that's right doing it all I know well
and again I think you know Andrew II
part of helping you make that decision
is actually come flying down looking
around looking at options seeing stuff
with your own eyes and looking at prices
because that's gonna that's gonna be
able to give you an answer pretty
quickly on what you think Nashville
versus Marquette vastly different I know
and I'm sorry Andrew if you came here
like 15 years ago it was so different it
was so different you could probably get
a bunch of land now
I want to sing If I Could Turn Back Time
Rachel but I won't because we'll be
taking off the air
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well you guys it's November and if you
can already feel it the holidays are in
the air and it's the best time of year
for many reasons but most important it
is this season for giving and if you
know anything about Ramsay you know that
we love Christmas and we love giving so
that's why we have a tradition the
Ramsey Christmas Cash giveaway you can
start entering now for your chance to
win it's our weekly 500 prizes or the
five thousand dollar Grands prize just
think about all all that cash what that
cash could do for your budgets so go to
ramsaysolutions.com giveaway and enter
every day to increase your chances to
win you can enter every single day no
purchase necessary and you must be 18 or
older to win that's ramseysolutions.com
giveaway and while you're there check
out some great gifts that maybe you can
give at the people in your life that you
love I have some personal favorites
there in the store and one of mine is
the 2023 Ramsay goal planner it's a
great way for you or someone you love to
win in the financial spiritual and
relational areas of your life so Dr John
zaloni George Campbell sitting next to
me and myself we've teamed up to help
you guys and your loved ones tackle
these goals with our monthly motivation
here in the goal planner so this is not
just a normal calendar George this is a
full-on
gold planner I mean it was so much
contents and of course you have your
calendar stuff in there which is
important but teaching there's a lot of
teaching and everything in here that you
need so make sure it's beautiful it is
beautiful
I know and the gold
I got to sign my first one from one
attendee in Sacramento Building Wealth
event last week yes or this week and you
got to sit and you got to sign the
Ramsey goal plan it was wonderful so
great so make sure to check them out
because they do sell out every single
year go to ramseysolutions.com
planner to get yours today and speaking
of you know giving stuff to your loved
ones uh to help them out tell them about
the show if you love this show make sure
to share it with a friend it costs you
nothing let me remind you yeah and just
spread the word and make sure to
subscribe and
um and you know rate the show everything
you need to do
um not rate it write and review you do
like rate it five stars and then you
leave it okay review as well you're
accurate Rachel yeah yeah lots of R is
happening yes I can guess yourself so
when it comes to shopping George though
there's so many options when it comes to
buying stuff we obviously teach the
debit card cash spending your own money
not going into credit card debt or
taking out loans but there's been a
sneaky way to pay for stuff that came in
came on the scene probably what 12 18
months ago in a big way the pot the buy
now pay later option and the jinsiers
love it and that means there's a lot of
debt associated with that oh yeah here's
an article from MSN buy now pay later
drives gen Z into debt and it goes into
a story about Sarah who saved 16 grand
for her future home by the time she was
18. amazing then she started doing using
buy now pay later products and quote
ruined everything in just two months she
racked up five grand across three of
these buy now pay later companies
ballooning balances alongside unexpected
medical costs drained much of her
savings and prompted her to seek help
from a financial advisor but the damage
was done her credit score dropped and
now she's 21 and her home purchase has
been set back by at least two years and
she's scared she won't even be able to
get a mortgage man it's really sad and
five of the major by now pay later
companies here cared these numbers
George have originated 180 million loans
totaling
24.2 billion dollars last year oh gosh
and let me remind you guys these are
loans
debt but they go Rachel I bought a 50
pair of jeans and it let me do an
installments of 12.50 a month
that's not alone it's a loan it's a loan
when you owe money to someone that is
debt and It's tricky because George
honestly if I if I didn't live by the
principles that we teach I'm a shopper
you know this I love to spend money and
when I check out majority of the places
I check out have that option at the
bottom by now pay later and they show
you what you just need to pay for right
now
and it's tempting you're like I like I
understand it's like it's 75 off what do
you think in your mind is that it well
then let me go add some more stuff
because I could I could spend a little
bit more than just that one payment I
mean it's it is crazy psychologists gen
Z is very anti like a lot of them don't
like credit cards but they don't see buy
now pay later is the same way because
like oh it's Rachel it's interest free
so like it's basically free money
that's the mentality yeah yeah but but
also when you don't pay back all that
all the fees in the back it's just
everything piles in too so and we talked
about this on you know I did the podcast
the fine print and you were the guest
for the episode later and we talked
about how beyond all the fees and
interest what by now pay later does so
well is causes you to overspend because
now your 50 card is a 12.50 cart so you
go well I can add more because I was
going to plan on spending 50 bucks yes
so I could have four times as much stuff
for the same price except you owe that
every single month with fees and
interest and that means you can't spend
that money on something else that's
right there's opportunity cost there yep
and so it it leaves you not in a good
spot just like who was it Sarah here
Sarah said man sixteen thousand dollars
saved and now now she's deeply in debt
so don't fall for this marketing uh gen
Z or anyone else because it's not just
gen Z that's falling for this it's
anyone who doesn't want to use their
money now or they don't have the money
and they don't have options for you know
credit cards and things like that some
people don't get approved but yeah by
now pay later is very lenient they're
happy to give you these micro loans so
if you want to learn more about that you
can check out episode 4 of the fine
print on the Ramsay Network or wherever
you listen to podcasts and you can hear
Rachel and I's take on it there that's
right all right up next we have Sarah in
Wellington Florida hey Sarah welcome to
the show
thank you thank you uh for having me
absolutely
how can we help
um so I'm 17 and I ride horses and I'm
at the age where my mom isn't really
paying for it as much as she used to so
right now
I pretty much pay for all my riding
lessons I pay for most of my show fees
and once I turn 18 I'm pretty much on my
own
um and I love writing I would love to
have my own horse someday but I also
want to be able to stay for my future
and I'm just not sure how to be able to
like follow my dreams and riding but
also be able to stay for my future so
like one day when I have the money buy
an apartment or a house or whatever yeah
well I appreciate you calling Sarah and
at 17 you sound very very mature okay so
tell me this what are your plans
at 18 for Life are you going to go to
school or are you going to go to a trade
school are you going to go straight into
the workforce what are you thinking is
going to happen when you turn 18.
um that's like also one of the things
I'm having trouble deciding like do I
want to go to a college and study
something with horses and be able to
like work my dream job
um this way I have the writing
opportunities I want or do I go into
something like law and be able to make
the money but I'm not doing something
that I love as much
sure well I would say this your degree
doesn't necessarily have to dictate and
pinch and hold you you know to something
very very specific so if you don't know
exactly what you want to do I would go a
little bit more broad that has you know
market value to know that what you're
going to make
um and so maybe something that's not as
specific and niche as you know horses
because what kind of degree what kind of
degree in studies I don't know what is
that Sarah
um so there's a lot you could study with
horses there are different colleges that
have different programs so they have
like Barn management which is like the
equivalence to business management but
to running your own barn or there's
training some colleges have writing
programs where you could learn how to
ride
um the question is there at the end of
that if you get any of those degrees are
there actual jobs that pay you enough to
still survive and live your life and
afford the horse and afford to buy a
house and those kinds of things what I
don't want is you have to live in the
barn with the horse because you're
getting paid 12 an hour with your degree
it depends like I'm lucky enough that I
live in a very horse populated area I
didn't know that was a thing a high
horse population yes okay so Sarah we're
about to head into a into a break but
what I would tell you is keeping your
options open not pigeonholing yourself
so tightly into something that you can't
have other options if you decide to do
something else later down the road I
think would be smart when it comes to
your college and then you need to know
okay how much is this going to cost for
me to still enjoy this Hobby and then
how much do you need to make to live off
of and enjoy the hobby but your hobby
might have to go on pause depending on
how much money you bring in and that's
okay because you can always go back to
it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show we're
taking your calls it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
George Campbell up next we have Brandon
and Lafayette is that how you say it I
think it's Lafayette Brandon correct us
if we're wrong man you know
Southern to me yeah Brandon how do you
say it properly how's it going it's
Lafayette
love it is is Lafayette there's a
Lafayette Tennessee
Tennessee says things same way they also
say Lebanon Lebanon Maryland
it's not Lebanon Lebanon Marvel all
right Brandon sorry we're here for you
how can we help
it's all right it's not the worst that
I've heard but there you go it's okay
but um so my question is
um my wife and I were relatively new
listeners and we kind of did the plan
backwards starting off because we didn't
really know but we kind of started
investing into an a Roth IRA and our
brokerage account
um for about three years now and we have
some loans that we want to pay off by
the end of the year but depending on the
Forgiveness
um I guess two scenarios might happen if
we do get the forgiveness
um we'll be able to pay everything off
but only have about three thousand left
over but
um if we don't get the forgiveness
um I guess I'm wondering do I tap into
my brokerage account or the Roth IRA
okay so how much you how much you guys
owe
um right now it's sitting at about 70
000. okay
and how much is in the brokerage account
um right now it's about like 22 to 23.
okay
um so I'll tell you what I would do
Brandon that's kind of how I usually
answer these questions is if I were to
wake up in your shoes George you can
give your your thoughts as well it may
be different we don't know yeah we don't
know we're about to see so if I were you
Brandon yes I would take or I'm sorry I
have one more question for you do you
guys have any just cash
around
in a savings account yeah we have in a
high yield savings we have
um we have about 62
000 right now okay
um yeah so that's the thing so if they
if they do give us 10 000 of forgiveness
we'll be able to pay it all off with
just you know our money and our savings
account but we'll only have about 3 000
left over so and you know in that
scenario I'm also wondering do I take
out money from my brokerage account to
kind of kick start my emergency savings
yeah so okay here's what I would do if I
were you I a brokerage Academy it's it's
fine I'm sure are using it for single
stocks and and moving that money around
yeah yeah so so that's so I I'm not a
fan of that way of investing period and
so if I were you I would just take the
23 000 out of your brokerage account
take the remaining out of your savings
or 62 000 and pay off this 70 000 today
today and then what you have left in
your hydro savings account is probably
enough to cover your three to six months
worth of expenses that we talk about in
baby step three
and then from that point on then I would
just continue to fund your Roth IRA I
would not touch it period uh I would
continue to fund it and fund you know
some good gross stock mutual funds look
into some other retirement investing as
well and then if this student loan
forgiveness actually goes through
then you can do a refund and actually
apply for that and get the money back if
that's what you guys choose to do but I
would not Brandon sit and wait for that
to go through because it's going to take
an act of God for all of this to go
through and with the midterms coming up
and possibly even you know depending on
what the Senate does you know the House
of Representatives like I just never put
my faith in politics it feels so shaky
to me and apparently the Supreme Court's
wanting to get involved into this whole
student loan forgiveness thing too I
mean like it's going to be a bloodbath
it's just why it's crazy and it may go
through I mean who knows but it's it's
not I mean they're we're not seeing
something happen at you know here in the
next
at the end of the year for instance you
know here in the next 60 days so again
if it goes through sometime next year
you can always do a refund and get that
back but if I were you I would not sit
and wait I would I would pay this off
and I'd be and I'd be done with it and
move on to investing yeah the way you
described all this you guys are so so
driven and uh you know you didn't do the
baby steps in order that's okay because
tomorrow imagine this you're completely
debt free with a pile of money in the
bank
man that is a different place to be and
now every dollar that comes in stays
with you you're not worried about what's
going to happen with student loans and
you can continue to keep saving and you
know what's your next goal Brandon do
you guys have another goal in mind
yeah um definitely probably need a new
vehicle at some point the next year or
two but um definitely probably start a
family soon um so my wife she just
graduated from school so she just got a
job so we can kind of start and you know
just to get on with our lives that's
what we kind of just want to do and you
know stop looking at this pile of stop
looking around the mirror that's awesome
what's your what's your household income
once she starts working
so she started working like two weeks
ago and so we just probably hit around
180
um before taxes or anything that's
incredible that's great now imagine 180
minus you know Uncle Sam staying with
you and you guys can save up you're
going to be able to upgrade your car in
no time you're gonna be able to save up
and you know purchase property and
invest and just build wealth like crazy
I mean you guys are so young you're
doing incredible so you can you can do
what you want to do but man you cash out
that brokerage account and never look
back and pay off all this debt you're
going to be an amazing spot financially
yeah yeah I think you know I have it in
my head that I'm definitely not waiting
past the end of the year so
um I think I'm studying that as my line
so if nothing happens at that point I'm
most likely just gonna take it out and
pay it um but yes I mean I guess in the
in the chance that they do forgive it
and we're able to pay it off with just
the money in our bank account we'll have
about 5 000 left over do you think at
that point I'm still cashing out that
brokerage
yeah because because so much of you know
that money it is kind of just playing
playing the stock game and in general
we're just not a fan of that you know
looking at yeah what's gonna over time
where is my money actually gonna make
money and there's a sense of you know
it's a little it's a little bit of that
kind of gambling feel of playing the
single stocks game and seeing what you
can do and over the length of time we've
just found that you know spreading your
money around something like just a good
mutual fund it's not as exciting it's
not as like but it's also a lot of
stressful and anxiety-inducing because
you're watching that single stock jump
up and down and you get the adrenaline
and you get the anxiety man if you're
going to start a family and you're going
to be a dad and I just don't want you
worrying about that and losing sleep
over what your single stock is doing
when I got into the Burger's account I
wasn't really you know too knowledgeable
about all the different ways to invest
and stuff so I haven't really put any
money any money into that in a while
yeah so I just kind of been hanging on
to it because it kind of dipped down so
I was just waiting to see if it would
come back up no I hear you it might be
worth the wait yeah and there's no fatal
errors here you know you're you're a
smart guy Brandon obviously you know you
know what you're doing and so I think
it's just putting a little bit more of
that knowledge a little bit more of that
predictability in place but um but I
know you threw out the option of a Roth
IRA using some of that so we didn't
really touch on that but I would just
say for everyone listening do not touch
your retirement investing don't touch
your 401k your Roth IRA it's not worth
the penalties yes the fees
um the taxes everything you know well
with Roth but the all the all the extra
that comes with it when you cash out
early not at retirement age so
the brokerage account make sure you're
working with your tax Pro because there
will be tax implications on all the
growth that you've experienced account
and so you want to make sure you're
planning for that you know how much
you're going to owe all that good stuff
but Rachel I just got a message the
other day from a guy who's now on the
Ramsey plan but he wasn't before he was
playing with single stocks in his Robin
Hood account he had made some money yeah
he was excited about it then he got into
options trading which is one of the
riskiest types of trading you can do and
he showed me his Robinhood account it
was at 10 000 and now it's at zero
because of his options trading he lost
it all he lost it all
and so he was kind of showing me you
know that was him going I got burnt on
the hot stove and I'm just done playing
that game I know that's and I hate that
he had to learn the lesson that way I
just want to tell everyone just don't be
that guy yeah you can avoid it when you
look at the market long term
this is the time to get in number one
because it's low while everyone's
freaking out put your money and continue
to invest because then you get to enjoy
the write-up and again it's predictable
when you're playing the single Sox game
it's all up in the air but when you know
you're in it for the long term investing
and boring things like a mutual funder
in the crock pot in the world full of
microwaves that's right that's right
thank you George for a great hour of
radio thank you America for listening
and everyone in the booth helping work
this guys appreciate you this is the
Ramsey Show
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS of
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz sitting beside Ramsay
personality and my co-host of the smart
money happy hour George Campbell we are
here taking your calls it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five so give
us a call we'll talk about your your
money your life your relationships your
jobs anything and everything you just
give us a call
all right starting us off this hour is
at Craig and St Louis hey Craig welcome
to the show
how are you guys doing doing great doing
great how can we help
well here's my history on baby steps too
and we're going through the steps and
we're at the
part of the program where we um we're at
the smallest Bill and technically we our
church had a capital campaign and we um
that we would contribute um so much over
the five years and we're down to 38.50
on that but that's zero interest on
anything and it's
we got a payment plan of 150 per month
for that until it's paid off I'll
basically have that if we stayed on that
way uh paid off in two years again it's
no no interest but I've got a truck
payment that's 8 500
and I that's the next one next step up
I've got 300 credit cards
and I want to try and get all this uh
this stuff taken care of but I wanted to
know should I I'm also a real estate
agent and I've got a transaction that's
going to be coming out that could pay
off a big chunk of the 8500 or I could
just totally pay off the church
contribution which would you do okay
it's a great question well we teach yeah
the debt snowball and it's about paying
your smallest debt off first to your
largest regardless of the interest rates
and so we're not really playing that you
know the interest rate game here it's
really about knocking out those smallest
debts first which are really important
okay you mentioned you mentioned credit
cards how much was that again you say
300
no um I've got three credit cards three
credit cards what are the balances on
those
um
there are 12 and one is 15.
15.
100 15
000.
yeah 12 000 and uh two or twelve
thousand and one is fifteen thousand
okay okay so till about 39 on those
right we've been living la vida loca
Craig what have we been doing
what was the majority of the spending on
those
just living life and it just um
we we finally I we finally did to where
we're done with it about six seven
months ago and we're just collecting our
nose we've stopped using the cards but
we've you know just got to go through
the steps and and uh
but uh but use them and pay them off
awesome and we're doing little by little
like I said we're trying to go gazelle
and fence on on this smaller stuff and
it's working but it's just uh it's
taking some time just wanted to know
which one which one you would do first
for sure well yeah I would knock out the
church at first because it's the
smallest and then I'd be knocking out
the truck next and then hitting on that
twelve thousand dollar card the next 12
000 and then the fifteen thousand to
stick to the debt snowball how much you
guys make a year
about 170 000. okay I love it great
income to clean up this pile of debt and
for sure how quickly do you think you'll
do that with with some gazelle intensity
and doing the dead snowball I
I but we're also our daughter is
finished up she's got a year left in
college and we got a 529 and we've been
paying cash for that
um so we're anticipating probably to
take
anywhere from two to four years four
years
I'm just kind of going off
that's how I think it looks like man I
just think making 170k and if I'm adding
up your debt correctly if you told us
everything you got about 51 000 in debt
I still I also have a mortgage still and
um and that's what he wanted and I'm
counting that in there too oh how much
is the how much is the equity line
equity line is uh 50. 50. okay so I
would add that in your desk yeah I would
add that into your debt snowball too
correct because if it's less than half
of your annual income
right I would I would add that as well
so talking closer to 100K 100K outside
of your mortgage
right right and you can use I'm using
every dollar or using the debt snowball
app that we all that we have
We are following um I don't have the
every dollar app but we are definitely
doing
a budget that we are definitely
following you know smallest to largest
and doing doing that way sweet well we
want to gift that to you to help you
along this journey so hang on the line
Jenna's gonna pick up we're gonna gift
you every dollar premium it'll connect
your bank it'll help you get an even
better plan for every single dollar
coming in and along with that we're
going to get you one year of Financial
Peace University to motivate you
encourage you equip you with some
knowledge and it's one of the best ways
to stay motivated when you've got a big
chunk of debt like that and you've got a
two three year slog ahead of you I think
this is really going to help so watch it
with your family watch it with your wife
and man call us back when you're debt
free it's gonna be a great story yeah
and Craig you know looking at these
numbers and adding that extra fifty
thousand so yeah it's bumping up to 100
101 000 making 170 though you know
living on nothing we kind of the joke
around here is like rice and beans beans
and rice you don't go out to eat you're
not going on vacation like you are doing
nothing until this debt is cleaned up
and man I focusing so so much on it and
then even say okay what are the things
that we can what are ways that we can
cut our expenses and also make extra
like is there a period of six months
where you say all right starting in
January till May we're going to be
working extra jobs and seeing how much
we can bring in and then we're going to
reevaluate I mean the the more you
sacrifice and the harder you work the
more you work the more hours you put in
to be making money the more to throw out
the stat and the faster you'll get out
so Craig I'm excited for you guys I can
hear in your voice that you're like we
are done we are done uh and and it's
amazing what that sacrifice of getting
out of debt the baby step two how
powerful it is and you have yeah two
three three and a half years ahead of
you
so it's gonna be a marathon it's not
gonna happen overnight but we hear those
stories all the time yeah around here
Rachel I wonder sometimes the high
income earners it's harder for them to
do this plan because it involves a level
of sacrifice where you have to swallow
your pride and you have to drive the
crap your car and you have to do the
side job and people are going whoa I
thought they were doing great I saw him
delivering pizzas yeah yeah wow and that
hurts and so for the high income earners
sometimes our plan can be harder in a
sense for them emotionally and mentally
no it's okay financially it's great
because you have a giant shovel that's
right that's right it's hard because you
have to live like no one else it's that
emotional side of it that's right it's
the humility to say man we screwed up
and we're gonna do what we have to do to
get out of this regardless of what other
people are thinking and it does it sucks
to be like we're gonna go backwards well
the House of Cards comes crumbling down
the life you thought you were actually
living when it was really just on
payments that's exactly but we're
excited for you Craig way to go man
remember when you when you pay off those
those credit cards cut them up get rid
of them don't let the Temptation be
laying around this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz co-hosting today with George
camel we're taking your calls at AAA
825-5225 here on the Ramsey show up next
we have Keith in Louisiana hey Keith
welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
okay so
um
I just recently retired in February
um I'm 62 years old headed career for 42
years
and finally stepped down and retired
um
I followed y'all baby steps uh I've been
following y'all for about five years now
and followed the baby steps so I also
went to a stock master and uh got an
advisor good yeah you know I went
through that process and
um I'll feel them on baby step six now
so my question is
uh still left with my house moved I
still owe like 120 000 on my home
um I don't have a big house note but um
I still have that let's say monkey on my
back which is bothering me so just
trying to figure out what I should do to
maybe pay it off
awesome well I'm proud of you man that's
incredible so you found us five years
ago which was in your late 50s right
correct I was a slow starter let's say I
had some issues getting started uh we
had Hurricane Katrina away and things
like that so well you're an inspiration
to many Keith because a lot of people go
well I'm 57 what's what hope is there
for me it's too late I'm like
57 you still have a lot of Life to Live
and you decided it's not too late for me
I'm going to retire with dignity and I
want to pay my house off so where are
you at financially do you have money a
nest egg do you have retirement money
I have enough to eat and I have
retirement money extra generating uh
monthly income
is like a pension
uh I took the Lonesome okay
instead of a monthly catching so walk us
through your kind of net worth
I had
1.7 million
amazing Keith what's that in
um it's Diversified they have it in a
little bit of everything Iris uh
I have my advisor has I I'm not very
good with this deal after these years
but they have it Diversified enough the
way it's generating some money for me
well no one mistakenly acquires 1.7
million so you've done some really
intentional stuff along the way have you
talked to your advisor about the best
strategy and use of this money uh you
know if there's Roth portions and
there's traditional portions what's best
to use first if you're going to take
some of this money and pay off the house
not yet I haven't talked to her yet
about it um we we meet quarterly on WE
very very often actually calls me you
know pretty often when things change and
they move stuff around if they need to
at the market
um but yeah that's great so yeah I would
talk to her Keith because she's a smart
investor Pro so she's very familiar with
uh the Ramsay baby steps and so she'll
know that yes you still have this 120
house payment or a mortgage but what's
great Keith is it's just a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars compared to one
point seven million so you are but it's
got me so nervous though yeah I know but
I think you can pay it off very quickly
so I would recommend in the next yes
that next quarter telling her that
because remember this always regardless
whether it's a smart investor Pro or
you're using a tax professional these
people work for you Keith this is your
money that's seven that 1.7 million
dollars you did that you this is your
money and she's there to advise you
because she is in the ins and outs of
the investment world and so it's always
good to have someone on your side like
that but what you're feeling is that
urgency of like I just want to get this
paid off and so
pay it off tell her I want this paid off
so what is the best way to get a hundred
and twenty twenty hundred twenty
thousand dollars right now to me so that
I can get rid of this mortgage because
financially you are in a 1 000 great
place to do that Keith
um and then you're able to let the rest
of that 1.6 you know uh be able to
continue to continue to grow and uh what
a fabulous job though Keith you've done
a remarkable job so congratulations and
I'm excited to have your house paid off
ASAP retirement and you are yeah you're
gonna be able to enjoy so
congratulations and again that's a
little bit of a shout out to our smart
investor Pros they are all over the
country you guys and they are investment
professionals that have the heart of a
teacher and they know the Ramsey Baby
Steps so they really do walk with people
when it comes to your investing because
it's an intimidating part of your
financial picture you know when you're
talking about Roth IRAs and 401ks and
mutual funds you know it's like well
what's capital gains when do I get taxed
when it's you know my income bracket you
know if I'm switch if I'm gonna be
moving and Selling Houses you know like
they're they are able to look at your
entire Financial picture and really
really help you with that side and
having people that that's their job it's
the ins and outs it's like what they eat
and breathe every single day it is so
helpful yeah we both have Smart investor
Pros because I'm not in the ins and outs
I don't know what's happening in the
industry and they're thinking about
things at a different level
strategically what if you move this over
here and you could actually use this
charitable deduction and I'm going oh I
had no idea that's surprising and so
they're so knowledgeable Beyond just
helping you you know just choose an
investment you feel like you're a bigger
Financial picture your legacy your net
worth what is the best use how do I
Steward this really well and
strategically and they know all the ins
and outs they know the laws they know
the codes I mean it's incredible so if
you don't have one go to
ramsaysolutions.com and go to Ramsay
recommends and connect with one in your
area today it gives you such peace and
such confidence absolutely all right up
next we have Laura in Philadelphia hey
Laura welcome to the show
Hi how are you we're doing well thanks
for calling
okay so
um my I'm 30 years old so is my husband
uh most of my 20s was spent spending
money and my poor husband he um is not a
sender when he does spend he could spend
big but he doesn't
um the
we're up to making a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars together a year before
bonus
um
my question is we have so we sold our
house
um this year actually and we moved
back to State and uh we paid off about
forty thousand dollars worth of debt
nice congratulations
yes it did take a big chunk off but we
still have fifty thousand dollars worth
of Consumer Debt
um our one car is almost paid off we
have about 2 900 left on it
um so I have that part of our snowball
my other car
we bought it uh brand new it's a leased
um my lease payment is almost 500 a
month
I am sick and tired of it I finally had
my I had it moment
um
and I called the dealership they will
take it back we are over miles we still
have a year left on the lease
um and they would take it back and we
wouldn't know anything
but we wouldn't get anything out of it
so we would have to go buy a car in cash
um and it would be you know a d car and
um
so yeah I'm just really nervous because
we do have a two-year-old
and I you know my husband was a mechanic
he's he's in a corporate office now
um in management but he I mean he does
have the tools he does have the
knowledge to fix a car good what's
what's the early buyout on it have you
asked them
so if I wanted to buy it out today my
residual value is right around 34 000.
okay and that's pretty much what they're
going to buy it back for
um so if you bought it from them what
would it cost and if you could resell
that after
so that's
a thought uh it's a Toyota 4Runner so it
does you know hold its value
um
I've been following it is people that
give it back it's it's the most money
you can lose on a lease which is already
a terrible way to get a car but if you
did the buyout and then you sold that
car do you guys have the cash to do that
so no and that's why I was very scared
to do that I didn't want to buy it out
and get into a larger finance payment
and then get stuck with it and not be
able to sell it yeah this may just be
one of those stupid tax scenarios where
you go never again that was a dumb move
and it hurt and I don't want to feel
that pain again so you may just need to
give it back at that point and get you a
used car with cash so you can fix up for
now until you're out of debt and then we
can upgrade later making 130 you guys
are going to get out of this thing fast
and upgrade so we're rooting for you way
to go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for ways to update your home without
blowing the budget I've got it for years
I've been telling you about our friends
at blinds.com blinds.com makes it simple
to shop top quality blinds Shades and
interior shutters from home with easy
online ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
s.com blinds.com 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from Meredith in Wisconsin I'm 27 years
old and trying my best to do the baby
steps so I can buy a house with a was at
with as little debt as possible but I
feel like in today's market it's nearly
impossible to find a decent house that's
affordable how can I accelerate my
savings to buy the house I really want
that is currently outside of my budget
this is a tough one Rachel there's a lot
of people especially in their 20s and
30s frustrated right now with how the
housing market has been the last few
years and with wages not increasing at
that rate they're going this isn't fair
now the average house is 400 grand and
I'm making 30 40 50. how am I ever going
to save up a down payment in order to
get the house that I really want yep
well I think that's the phrase there
it's what I want right and so it's not
always about what you want it's what you
can afford even if it's not a lot and
and it and it does like it it sucks that
you look back and you're like if in 2019
it was a different world and here we are
in 2022 and it's not that prices have
you know significantly dropped it's
slowed down the market has which is
great for buyers you have a little bit
more room for negotiation and all that
but it's still a lot of places have
still held that value even when it's
spiked up so
um it you know
I I feel like I'm gonna sound cold
George No usually that's yours usually
it's me I'm very happy you're the one to
do this take note America but I'm like
but what sucks is like math doesn't care
heartless doesn't have emotion and so we
can sit and complain about it because it
does suck like I mean yeah
but if you just sit there and complain
then what else are you gonna do so you
have to be able to say okay here's the
reality here's the reality I'm not gonna
be able to buy in that county that I
wanted to right now I'm gonna have to
you know go 20 minutes further out than
I was expecting to get that kind of
house or I'm gonna have to stay in the
area I want to buy in but my house is
going to be significantly smaller than
what I was expecting and so again that's
not fun none of you want it you want
what you want
but when the numbers aren't there you
have to deal with okay where are the
numbers playing out for me if I really
want to buy a home and I mean it's not
fun but that's the truth that's what you
have to do because it's not going to be
a great thing you know being a homeowner
it's wonderful and we want everyone
eventually too because it's a really
smart place to put your money
financially but it also is so
emotionally driven sometimes for people
that they jump in without you know doing
the due diligence of having a secure
Foundation of not having payments not
having debt having an emergency fund
being wise as they get into it making
sure again even what they're buying
isn't out of their budget and uh is it's
it's hard but it's what you got to do
now oh yeah it makes me think of that
old adage
cheap faster good you can only choose
two
you know if you want it cheap and fast
we can do that but it won't be good
you know and so there's a level that you
have to compromise sliding scales when
it comes to housing of all right I
really want that house either it's going
to take more time yeah to get the house
that I want or I can do it faster but
I'm gonna have to go 30 minutes into the
next County and it might be a condo
instead of the single family home right
and it might need a few upgrades that I
have to make a few years from now
because it doesn't have the kitchen that
I wanted with the backsplash and so we
talked about this on Smart money happy
hour in our first episode about how HGTV
ruined our generation they ruined our
lives because the exercise
yeah now we're like everyone hated their
house after watching chip and Joe make a
house beautiful like I want to do that
and so there's a level of patience that
we need resetting expectations and on
top of that she's asking how do I
accelerate my savings and me and my wife
we did this when buying our first home
which the Nashville area is super
expensive we live in one of the
wealthiest counties in the nation here
in Williamson County Tennessee and we
decided all right we're gonna get a town
home for our first home we don't need
need a giant single-family home for Just
the Two of Us
yep and so we did that we increased our
income I was taking on side jobs I was
building websites I was hosting outside
events I was doing all kinds of things
just to bring in extra income to save up
for that down payment we did no spend
months we cut a lot of luxuries and
subscriptions and things that we would
have loved to do as a newlywed couple
but we went you know what the house is a
priority over that vacation
and those are the kinds of things you
have to really grapple with in order to
have the things you want yep for sure
you know I took Winston and I close to a
decade almost 10 years to get to the
point that we're like okay we're going
to upgrade to the next home and it was a
long goal it was a long goal that we
knew and even toward the end we weren't
quite we wanted so yeah we were we were
cutting stuff I was yeah I was taking on
any kind of speaking thing I could yeah
I was like I was saying yes to
everything there's a kind of a gazelle
intensity to it of that yes toward the
end which was which was great because we
we needed it and that's what we wanted
that was our goal but here's the thing
too George is it's not worth having a
home it feel you know for someone that's
looking
mostly for your first time home buyers
again we want you to get to that place
where you can own a home because it's
it's just smart financially
but that it looks So Glamorous from the
outside and when people make a move a
bad financial move into something they
can't afford I would say the mental
health the stress the anxiety
it offsets what you thought this house
was going to be and how great it was
it's like oh my gosh I would rather go
back to where we were and rent and not
have the stress that we have now and so
there's there's a give and take there
when you go and you move into something
you can't afford it's it's not it
doesn't create a glamorous experience
here's the big takeaway you can tweet
this Rachel thank you home ownership is
not the antidote to your lack of
happiness
it's not wow it's not going to be there
because home ownership has a lot of
costs and on top of that most people
that do it prematurely they're also in
debt in other areas so now you have the
car payment you have the student loans
you have the credit cards you have your
money and then let me say this on the on
the emotional contentment side George
you take you with you into the new house
too
Rachel is ice cold today and we love to
see and there's something about it
because I went through this too where I
was like I just want a different kitchen
I would be if life would just be better
if we had a bigger kitchen you know I
had all these thoughts now life would be
better if you went to therapy and got
control of your marriage how about that
and so then I look at them like oh my
gosh but like you're a lot it's still
you moving in even if it's a bigger
kitchen it's still all that
discontentment that you have another in
other parts of your life too so it's
it's not the end I'll be all right so
there's a hilarious Tick Tock out there
that I think sums up the frustration
that America's feeling do you want to
see it I would love to see it okay let's
roll that
how is any young person ever gonna own a
home it's maybe Hate Old People I see a
few of you in here tonight I hate you
because every old person in a city like
LA or New York or London is the same
they're like my house is worth two
million dollars but when I bought it in
1981 I paid 11 raspberries for it
one person's like I have died roommates
[Laughter]
we each pay eleven thousand dollars a
month every single one of us is a lawyer
except for Ted and every single own
person's like I'm a librarian with a
home at the beach oh my goodness
that while it's an exaggeration that is
hilarious to that yes a lot of the
pressure's coming from parents who by
the way raise their kids to go follow
your passions at all costs and go 300
000 into the student loan debt and then
they're like why are you married why do
you have a house yet where are the
grandkids give us and they're like dude
I can't even breathe I can't get to next
week let alone buy a house and so this
doesn't just fall this is not to blame a
generation this is to go listen we've
made some mistakes we have to accept
responsibility and we have to accept the
reality that home prices are insane now
what are we gonna do that's right what's
next and having options that's another
thing you know and you can add School
College on top of this the tuition how
insane it's gotten I mean all of it so
all this stuff has and so what it does
it forces you to look and say okay
what what is the wisest route because
it's not just like oh you have to own a
home tomorrow or you have to go get a
college degree right like it's not the
it's not that black and white anymore
it's like okay what what can I afford in
this moment where do I want to be in
five years right and so working towards
something as well yes but it is and it
starts it's hard guess what I have to
get out of debt first and have an
emergency fund and then save up the down
payment and yes that might be three four
five six years from now but when you get
there you're gonna have a piece about it
you did it with intentionality
no regrets right Rachel
George it'll never die God bless you God
bless you my friends good story this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
debt is smart investing and saving is
smart but there's one key to winning
with money that people Overlook all the
time and that's protecting your finances
from emergencies and that's where
insurance comes into play so now there
are about 10 different kinds of
insurance coverage that you might need
based on what your life looks like today
so we built a tool called coverage
checkup to show you which types that you
need to add drop or adjust will even
rank your coverage list by importance
email it to you and connect you with a
Ramsay trusted insurance provider so
that you can plan and play you can put a
plan in place fast
and seriously you guys it takes five
minutes and it might be the most
important five minutes that you spend
today uh Donald H wrote in and said for
anyone who has not completed this
checkup do it now you never know when
something will happen and you never want
to leave your family in a bad situation
that's exactly right so visit
ramseysolutions.com checkup that's
ramseysolutions.com
checkup and don't let don't let an
emergency sneak up on you protect your
family now
yeah insurance is a important part of
this George it's offense and defense you
don't need to know a lot about sports to
understand that metaphor but you can
build wealth but keeping it and
protecting it is a whole other ball game
so proud that you that you use Sports
analogy well with your Tennessee Vols
doing well Rachel I know I decided to
learn so you gave me some Spark Notes
earlier I did but the top four teams can
Tennessee make it to the SEC
Championship even if they lose Georgia
possibly we'll see all right we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five and up next
is Dustin in Pittsburgh hey Dustin
welcome to the show
thanks guys uh great job on the smart
money Happy Hour podcast oh thanks
Dustin appreciate that appreciate that
yeah so I've got a question
um about where I'm at in the baby steps
and whether or not I should continue to
be gazelle intense and contribute to the
match in my 401k at work um while I'm
doing these steps and they're kind of
falling between baby steps three and
four uh so I'm I'm 24 years old I I'm on
baby step three and I'm probably gonna
finish off my three month emergency fund
by the end of this year
cool uh so my next few goals are to buy
out my car lease and that will take
roughly one year of saving
uh the second goal would be to buy some
rings and uh marry my girlfriend we've
we're going through FPU together we're
halfway through nice congratulations
thanks and then uh down payment on a
house so what do you guys think about
how I reach those goals like what
intensity level we should be at and
whether I should invest or not up to the
match at work
um
you're on a great path and you mentioned
you've got the car lease which would
technically put you in baby step two and
so do you know the early buyout amount
of that car
yeah I'm halfway through the lease and I
would say it's probably another three or
four thousand dollars uh if I don't buy
it out with cash
um
that's the only caveat on these plans
because other than that you know baby
step three and three B into four it's
kind of a Choose Your Own Adventure
based on your goals where you're at if
you want to invest 15 once you have the
fully funded emergency fund while saving
up the down payment it's gonna take
longer but that's a great option if you
want to split the difference and go I'm
going to invest in the match and then
the rest I'm going to save for the down
payment you can also do that some people
go scorched Earth and go I'm not going
to invest at all and I'm going to save
up this down payment really fast so
there's kind of three buckets you can
choose in that regard
okay so what about the car lease I was
planning on saving up for one year to
buy it out it's about 16 000 residual
value how much do you make Dustin
starting next year assuming a four
percent raise around 70 000 a year
okay
and what's the car worth
uh whenever I went into lease it it was
worth I'd say like 21 22 000 okay so
it'll probably around 16 17 by the time
you would do the early buyout yeah yeah
16 000. okay
yeah I mean it's not too much of your
world if you like the car and you want
to keep it at that point is that the
plan
yep yeah nothing but compliments on it
um and I you know I did the math figured
out it's only it'll only be like a
quarter of my take-home pay or uh the
gross pay anyway so yeah it's not like
it's a crazy vehicle
okay are you saying the payment
oh no the um the total value of the car
like the 16 divided by the 70 would
probably be like a quarter or a third oh
God I got it okay
cool yeah yes I mean I mean if you went
that route Dustin then obviously you
said it'll take you a year to save
um that amounts and then how much you
want to spend on a ring
um I was thinking about 5 000 for the
ring and leaning towards the
conventional wedding cost around like
you know
20 000 or under are you guys paying for
the wedding
yeah we haven't talked to our families
yet about it but um we've been together
for five years and I would like to get
married within the next two okay that's
great
um it all sounds reasonable on that end
yeah I mean you're just gonna this car
lease which I hate for you I'm like man
okay well that's what I use to keep my
car payment low while I was paying off
my student loans that I knocked out in
August but now you know I'm facing down
another big expense saving up to buy it
out yep that's right that's right yeah
so I would do it in that order
um I would be saying yeah the the ring
in the car obviously and then what you
guys can pull together Cash Wise for the
wedding
um because all because you know your
life is going to look so different in
two years and because of your age and
everything obviously investing is very
important and the earlier you start the
better off you are but I wouldn't lose
sleep over you know not doing that for
for two years because of where you're at
you just have a lot of life change it's
going to cause it's going to cost money
to do a lot of this stuff and so I just
want you to have the cash for it so
prioritizing it yeah so yeah the car and
the ring but I would pause investing
until you are out of that lease and you
have the fully funded emergency fund
yeah I would not be investing Dustin
until you have the emergency fund like
yes like George said and the car is
yours the ring and you guys are well on
your way saving for the wedding so if
that's a pause on investing for two
years then that's that's probably what
it's going to be and you're young you
got plenty of time to do that and I I
personally like the fire it lights under
you to go man I'm missing out on that
free money in the match I'm missing out
on compound growth and that's going to
actually Propel you to do the other
steps the problem is people get
comfortable because they go well I'm
investing a little bit I'm saving a
little bit I'm paying off a little bit
of debt yep I'm good but the problem is
you don't really make progress in any of
those areas because of that that's right
so thanks for the question Dustin
appreciate it yep all right up next we
have Sean in San Antonio hey Sean
welcome to the show
hey Rachel hey George how are you guys
we're doing great how can we help
it's so nice to talk to you guys I'm
extremely nervous but at the same time
um excited so I have
um a mortgage question I would like to
pay off my house just to basically have
more peace in my life I have the needs
to do so and it wouldn't take me all the
way down I would still have my emergency
emergency fund plus some
um I also have a three-year-old son my
fiance is in school full time for one
more year she's uh going into her senior
year and then we're gonna move
uh so my son is in a better school
district so I don't know if I should
keep liquid cash or just get the money
back when I sell
okay so when you sell are you when you
guys move from yes you're home okay so
how much do you have left on your
mortgage
ninety five thousand ninety five
thousand okay and how much do you have
in above your emergency fund
I would say above my emergency fund like
110 so I have 135 liquid okay so that
would leave a decent emergency fund on
top of that okay awesome I mean I'm 28
years old I'm self-employed I'm gazelle
intense I listen to Smart money happy
hour
um and I've just listened to Dave for
the past couple of years I've tried my
hardest to follow by y'all's you know
principles but it's hard sometimes but
I'm I'm gazelle intense yeah well you're
doing a great job Sean I mean the
numbers you just gave us and I'm
assuming you have no Consumer Debt this
mortgage is the last thing so yeah I did
it I've never had any debt in my life
besides this mortgage I've had it since
I was 19 and it's just one of those
things that I just want out of my life
but I know when we move we'll probably
end up getting a bigger house just
because that's just the way it's going
to go Sean get get the final payoff
amount from the mortgage lender and
you're gonna wire that money and be debt
free by tomorrow and then until you move
just stack up cash on top of that so
that when you do move you have all the
proceeds from your home sale plus this
other stack of cash man you guys are
going to be set great a great spot and
don't combine those finances until after
you're married Sean I know you said that
we're engaged so be saving for that
wedding too you guys get married and
that's so exciting Sean well done so
cool hard work has paid off well thank
you George for a great hour thanks to
all you guys in the booth and thank you
America for listening this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I am Rachel Cruz hosting
today with Ramsey personality and
co-host of the smart money happy hour
George Campbell so it's a free call
anywhere in the country at AAA
825-5225 all right starting us off this
hour is Tamara in San Diego hey Tamara
welcome to the show
hi
um yes this is me to Mary Simmons I'm a
college student I go to uh graceline
Community College
yes sorry about that I'm kind of nervous
because I watch you guys show like
all the time just oh we appreciate it
we're so glad you called today
wow you act like you just won a game
show all right I love it love the energy
what's your question how can we help
Okay so so um I'm in six thousand
dollars uh six thousand dollars in
credit card debt with Navy Federal with
the green card
and but I have a student grant that's
coming in
that's like four thousand dollars the
only thing is
um I'm a caregiver nurse and so I had
got ill from covert and scabies so
um
I couldn't my payments of you know
getting paid
went down the drain I'm so I'm sorry
guys I'm kind of nervous so you couldn't
work you couldn't work because you were
sick which means you missed a few
paychecks
yes okay are you working now
um it's really hard to get back into the
that field because uh I'm I don't have a
consistent client okay so it's only fill
in okay is there any other kind of
nursing you can do
um I applied for other jobs but since
it's because the nation shot oh this is
the
um covet vaccination
um I might have early I'm sorry allergic
reactions oh so you can't get the
vaccine which means they they won't hire
it's probably going to be a hard
industry to be in Tamara is there uh how
are you how are you paying your bills
right now are you making any kind of
income
so as in for right now I do doordash but
I only can make like 250 a night for
doordash but that uh that causes a lot
of problems to the car okay and I
already I already bought like three cars
in the past and I know how that goes
with cars how much money do you have in
the bank
so what I have in the bank right now is
about like uh thirty dollars but I know
my student grade is yeah I know my City
Grand is Gonna Come I've been
maintaining stuff I still have a phone
bill I have to pay I still have sdng I
have to pay so I kind of been paying
little stuff with doordash and when do
you get this when do you get the grants
the four thousand dollars
um they they told me next they told me
next week okay okay so yeah I would hang
on keep doing you know the doordash
whatever you can to continue to just
keep your head above water until you get
that Grant and then you're gonna have to
have yeah Plan B happening really soon
Tamara because that four thousand
dollars it's gonna go rather quickly and
so being able to say okay nursing in the
medical field you know I'm not having
the vaccination I'm assuming I'm not a
medical professional uh is going to be I
don't hurt your chances of finding any
employment in that field so if there's
something else that you're passionate
about
um and to be able to do something on the
side but I think while in school picking
up these side hustles is going to be
your best bet and even if it's you know
house sitting dog sitting
um yes the doordash the instacarts all
of that until you're out of school and
then finding something you know and and
even if it's it's not may not be in the
medical field George but I'm like even
um you know getting a uh entry level you
know assistant job or because you said
you were a caregiver Tamara so maybe
you're really great at helping and
serving people and it could be more in a
office setting versus a medical setting
uh but but really finding that is gonna
is gonna be huge and that six thousand
dollars of debts that you're going to
start to work to pay off and so that's
kind of cut up those cards please don't
even give yourself the option of going
further into debt that's right all right
up next we have Alex in Indianapolis hey
Alex welcome to the show
hey Rachel George can you hear me okay
yes we can how can we help
hey so I'll try to keep it brief I'm 33
and I just started a new job I'm trying
to figure out what to do with my
um money in my 401k for my old job so I
have about 430 000 in the brokerage
account kind of a bridge fund I was
saving up for 200 and Claire Roth IRA
and about 200 left from my old employer
401K so I had not known that I was going
to get a job right away so I paid about
an extra 70 grand as kind of a bridge
Zone
um until I found a job or if I want to
take a little sabbatical or something so
I'm trying to figure out if I should
either one invest or move the pre-tax
401K that 200 000
um into my Roth IRA and pay the taxes
with that 70 grand
or if I should just invest it and keep
going into my brokerage fund and kind of
that bridge on them I'm developing now
which will eventually probably be a
house fund where are you at in the baby
steps do you have any debt
what do you do Alex
uh I'm an engineer
um
my previous company for about 10 years
okay and they started a Ross 401K about
halfway through so half my money I've
already kind of moved out of that 401k
it's the pre-tax stuff that wasn't Ross
in that first five years that I right
right I was working there yeah I mean
that's we we would tell people you know
don't do the the Roth rollover because
of the tax burden until you're at baby
step seven but if you've got a paid for
house and you've got the money to cover
the tax burden on that great that could
be a great option to do a direct
rollover I would not cash it out and
invest that money because that will
create a whole new set of tax burden
that I don't want you to experience
because of all the penalties there so if
you do a direct rollover you'll avoid
all of that
but you'll pay for the taxes but you
have that 70 grand to cover it
yeah and that's you know and so I don't
own a house yet and that's what that 430
um is going to probably do once I get
through it and so that's kind of where
you know I'm chunking if you don't have
a house I would personally just do a
direct rollover to a traditional IRA
okay instead of the Rocks because 90.
use that for the house for that for a
down payment on the house yeah I would
use that bridge and broke Ridge outside
of an emergency fund I would use all the
liquid cash you have that's
non-retirement towards that house and if
you can pay cash man you're crushing it
I mean how cool would it be if you could
just pay cash for your first home
yeah that's what I'm looking forward to
I just I'm not going to be in the
location where I'm going to stay for
another two years my fiance she's a
foundation of fellowship and I know
we're going to move after that so sweet
so 35 you keep stacking on cash you pay
cash for your first home you're already
a millionaire but definitely do the
direct rollover to avoid any taxes in
the situation to the traditional IRA and
get the real estate to get that first
house yeah if you don't have a financial
advisor already a smartvestor pro go
connect with one of ramsaysolutions.com
a guy of you know with where you're at
financially you're going to be ultra
ultra wealthy and we want to make sure
that you are a good great Steward of
what you're building man that's awesome
great job Alex great job thanks for
calling this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five so George
normally I am very prepared for this
show and anything that's thrown my way
besides the callers I am I'm on the ball
but this I am not yes so we so I'm
really on the edge of my seat for what's
about a minimum of like 47 people have
sent me this video being like we need
you guys to react to this video we need
your thoughts on this is this true
what's your take and so Rachel has not
seen this I have seen it and we're going
to get Rachel's kind of blind reaction
here are you ready for this uh I'm not
even gonna set it up I don't even know
what's about to happen so if it's a
friend's clip I'll probably quote it it
is not a quote from Notting Hill I'm
probably gonna know this I don't know
hot money advice from social media oh
okay get ready
rich people help their kids get perfect
credit scores long before those kiddos
can apply for their own credit card and
it's not even that complicated I can
explain it to you I'm Vivian you're rich
BFF and your favorite Wall Street girly
who you follow for all the money Secrets
as soon as my kid is born I'm gonna set
them up as an authorized user on my
credit card as you can see with the
exception of discover and American
Express most of these credit card
issuers don't have a minimum age
requirement this means I will be issued
a credit card with their name on it but
I'll be responsible for paying the bill
and you're probably wondering what does
a baby need a credit card for they don't
instead of giving the card to them I'm
either gonna cut it or I'm just going to
put it in a safe location I will then
proceed to make on-time payments on my
credit card bill every single month by
doing so I'll start building good credit
for my kid allowing them to leech onto
my good credit by the time they finish
High School they'll have built a credit
history of 18 years and have a score in
the high 700s or even 800s this will
help them rent their first apartment or
qualify for a great credit card of Their
Own oh my gosh you know what I just went
to y'all what if someone watches that on
Instagram and they're terrible with
money they put their kid in this
situation and they don't pay their bills
on time does that mean you just screwed
your kids financial future like ding
ding ding ding that is so scary to me
Vivian I've seen her videos and she does
have some great videos I have seen her
there is a sharp young lady but we don't
agree the debt thing which we don't
agree with like anyone on social media
because we're I feel like we're the only
ones that talk about being debt free for
the most part so I don't agree with all
that but like that's scary to put that
out there and Trust the American culture
who has like average fifteen thousand
dollars a car Rachel this is what the
wealthy do okay this is what the true
Rich are doing to set their kids
literally gave me anxiety I don't have
anxiety I don't really like the anxiety
is not my thing but I just had it
that makes me so sad forget like can I
tell you Rachel anytime a bit like I
just I can't I don't trust it and the
fact that yes okay hold on hold on I
have so many thoughts okay okay and then
and then B is like you don't need a
credit score right like our thing is
like you shouldn't have a credit card
anyways you don't need a credit score
don't be like trying to like rig the
system to get a good credit score
because listen teach your kid to pay for
everything with cash and then when they
went home they can do manual
underwriting and they're fine so it's
unnecessary number one or number two but
number one she's advising people that
most of America is terrible with with
their credit cards so like they're gonna
screw their kids
right like is that is that correct am I
am I you just you just uh solve the
problem Rachel I went to the comment
section and the very first comment was
like my parents did this to me and they
taped my credit score by the time I was
18 because they mismanaged money and now
it screwed me over okay here's a
question I probably shouldn't even get
into this Wade in this water because I
don't know
but like I I've I have known two people
not like really close friends but enough
that they've like shared this with me
that they're I that their identity was
stolen from an aunt and uncle that
raised them oh and the uncle took this
right and I know that this is not
stealing your identity but it is weird
that you can put someone's
name
you know yeah but like
I don't know it creates a whole bunch of
future and potential problems and on
paper you know she's going well yeah if
you do it perfectly it could work out
great for your kid but there's a much
higher probability that you're going to
hurt your kid financially 18 years from
now and that creates resentment and they
go thanks Mom and Dad
oh I would be pissed if I turned 18 and
my parents were like sorry we tried to
help you but we got behind here and
there and now you're you got to dig
yourself out of this hole with this
credit score because you have a really
bad one even though you've done nothing
to it that you didn't
do you know how that's it's frightening
that is and you talk about how to
actually raise your kids when it comes
to money in smart money smart kids and
there's a lot of simple things you can
do that don't involve opening a credit
card for a baby what are we doing
America no oh that's so scary I know so
we talk about a lot on this show but you
know you can try to kind of like beat
the system and figure out how to do this
that that and that to win
when it comes down to it it is your
behavior what you choose to do with
money is how you're going to win and I
think one of the one of the gifts
parents can give their kids is teach
teach them how do you handle money and
actually show them hey you have to work
we're doing this with our kids are the
two girls at least Charles's
he's three and he just probably will
never I'll probably just give him money
all the time he's not already there's
just something in my heart about Charles
I'll be like you can just stay with me
forever but the girls were like okay you
know you got to do you know Caroline's
five now so there they are they're doing
chores and they understand okay if I
work here if I work and do this this and
this that we've very much communicated
then you get money and they're at the
young age where now they're not saving
up for anything they're five and seven
so we get to go to Target or a toy store
here in Nashville you know and they get
to spend some of their money in a few
weeks and they love it and it's great
and then as they get older you start to
teach them okay now that you know where
money comes from it comes from work now
we're gonna give We're Gonna Save and
we're gonna spend here are three things
that you can do with money and under our
roof you're gonna practice these things
you're gonna you're gonna make mistakes
and we're gonna allow you to make
mistakes and that's great uh you're
gonna get some victories and a little
bit of this like Dignity of oh wow I did
that and and and you can start to see
progress It's that behavior that you
want and still with your kids because
that's what gives them the dignity when
they leave home at 18 that they get to
go and win because they have the
knowledge and that's and that's my story
you know people think that some people
do I guess everyone's like well you know
you guys are good with money because
your dad just gives you money I'm like
you think Dave Ramsey like sends me
secret checks in the mail that would be
awesome if he did that would be great he
doesn't but the gift that they gave us
as kids is like understanding how to do
this stuff at 18 and so thank God you
know we were able to avoid debts and
know how to budget know how to save and
we're not perfect with money but
learning those Basics you get to start
that at 18 which is a gift where a lot
of people start you know 30s 40s 50s
even 60s they're way in the hole Yeah
because you know they they didn't know
this stuff
um but man that's the gift you want to
give your kids not trying to like
finagle this this debt playing industry
and how to work it and like no give them
the knowledge and the experience and
that that's what will take them places
absolutely this is and so I covered the
the whole debunking all the credit score
myths that she's talking about we need a
credit score to rent an apartment you
need a credit score and it's just not
true and I'm just tired of us
perpetuating these myths that cause
people to go into debt which by the way
is the only way to create a credit score
and maintain one is to do that and pay
it off perfectly every single Factor has
to do with debt and the problem here is
that it doesn't set your kid up for
financial success they can still be in a
pile of debt when they graduate college
because they have their great great
credit score right so if you want to set
them up set up a 529 or an Esa when they
when they're born and do that for 18
years now that's right that they can go
to school and pay for it because of yes
that's trying to help them start to do a
budget and show them how to manage their
money wisely as they get their first job
and show them that not having debt sets
you up and as we see these new
generations come up I think we're going
to see that where they go oh gosh
they're stressed out because they have
all these student loans I don't want one
of those yeah no thank you well there
was a article that I read a few weeks
ago and they talked about that even
within gen z uh a lot there's like you
know I mean every generation I know has
you know the the good eggs and the bad
eggs in the bunch but how they're
they're interviewing a couple of them
they said well I'm watching my older
siblings Millennials graduate you know
with yeah six figures of debt they're
stressed out because of what's going on
when you know the coveted shutdown
happened they didn't have savings and
they're like I don't want to be that yes
and so there is a little bit of that
rebellion of like whatever that system
was at the millennials to do why and the
Boomers were trying to play like I don't
want to do that so that's great we just
did a whole episode on Smart money happy
hour called scroll with caution how to
spat bad money advice on social media so
go check that out wherever you listen to
podcasts smart money happy hour just
released yesterday and we do a lot of
reacts to a lot of money advice out
there so hot takes and a lot of laughs
man yeah make sure to check that out
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz co-hosting today with the
one and only George camel wow there's a
lot of George camels out there you are
the one to know my George the one and
only well guys there's nothing I love
more than spending Dave's money and
giving it to you this time of year no
questions asked and uh and I still get
to keep my job at the end of it and that
is exactly what happens with the Ramsey
Christmas Cash giveaway it is back and
you could win one of our weekly 500
prizes or the grand prize five thousand
dollars no it's no Powerball but you got
a much better chance of winning this one
than the Powerball uh and you don't have
to spend a dime think about what having
that extra cash in your budget could do
you could uh buy a George camel portrait
to hang in your foyer you like that
Rachel Jorge you could use it to buy
Christmas gifts you could pay off your
smallest debt and get started on that
debt snowball so if you want to enter
this giveaway just go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
enter every single day to increase your
chances of winning no purchase necessary
but hey sorry kids if you're under 18
you cannot enter oh man hey tell your
parents to do it that's great
ramseysolutions.com giveaway and we're
just getting started with the cash
giveaway that's right we go all out for
Christmas we're putting our best selling
books and tools on sale for as low as 10
bucks that's right we are somehow
overcome inflation Rachel it's not the
11 sale it's the ten dollar sale so find
the perfect gift for literally everyone
on your list like Dave's book baby steps
millionaires Ken Coleman's book from
paycheck to purpose Dr John deloney's
questions for humans conversation cards
all new to the ten dollar sale and
Rachel if you go to the store right now
you'll notice there's a new item in
there oh merch we've never had this uh
Ramsay and it's here I've been waiting
for it because I see like shirts on Etsy
that are terribly designed with our
stuff on it I'm like oh we need to be we
could do it better than that and what do
you have George right now all those
watching on YouTube can see live like no
one else t-shirt it's very rock and roll
it is sporting it with a denim jacket uh
and it's it's super soft and the detail
is beautiful on it we can just go like
fashion blogger oh my gosh but it is fun
and so the team uh they gave me one of
these because I love free stuff and so
it's not free for you America but it is
uh it's up there on the store so if you
want some merch it's a great gift this
Christmas for people who've been
following the plan yeah and you want to
celebrate and it's a great conversation
starter at the grocery store they're
like what does that mean it's like
someone else it's a great way to do that
ramseysolutions.com you can shop our
biggest ten dollar sale yet uh and enter
the cash giveaway all right up next we
have David in Philadelphia hey David
welcome to the show
thanks Rachel and George for having me
on and George I want to start by saying
I like free stuff too yeah but I got an
interesting situation here to get your
opinion on
um my parents have had time shares for
over 40 years and one of the sales
pitches is you can pass it on your kids
well do I have to take them no if can
you turn down an inheritance and for
that matter could they rewrite a will
and give it to the salesman that sold it
to them in the first place
put it right back right back in their
pocket yeah I don't you definitely do
not have to accept a timeshare
and uh okay the good news is it's not
even an asset and so it's not like
they're you're inheriting an asset
you have a sense of ownership that's
what you're being sold with a timeshare
and uh it is not a gift it is not even
free there are crazy crazy costs as you
probably know associated with time
shares and it goes up every year
intentionally to make them more money
and make you more broke and have you
stuck at the same crappy rental that
your parents had for 40 years
sure so is there a good way to get out
of one for my mom at this point
um you know she's looked into a couple
of the services and some of the reviews
we're seeing or people talk about that
they're being told not to pay the
maintenance fees and it's ruining their
credit scores not that we're worried
about credit scores but it just seems
like it's a almost as bad of a thing to
get out of as it is to get into oh it is
it's almost it feels almost impossible
to get out of so yeah there are
um some companies that do it but you
yeah you want to be very specific on
which ones because I think there's some
terrible ones out there
um but there are some that that do so I
would I would look at uh really
investigating those calling them
um yeah I mean I guess you could look at
the reviews too but finding a certified
one that that actually has progress and
has testimonies for people that they
yeah that they've helped but it's a it's
hard that's what sucks about time shares
once you get in them it's it feels like
nearly impossible to get out it's not
easy and if you need convincing of this
go to eBay and go to sold and completed
listings and search timeshare and you
will see timeshares being sold for 99
cents
and it's kind of like a quick stand on
Gilligan's Island you just can't get out
of it exactly so uh do not accept this
under any circumstances just say no
thanks Tom Hanks to your parents and say
I appreciate that but I uh this is an
investment and I'm not prepared to take
on this investment because there's a lot
of fees associated with it and if it has
to die with them I'm okay with that
all right up next we have Dave in LA Los
Angeles hey Dave welcome to the show
hi Rachel hey George uh thank you for
taking my call I really appreciate it
absolutely how can we help
um so I just took a job offer that uh it
was a 16k pay cut and I'm kind of
thinking whether or not I should still
like talk to them again and tell them
hey like it's uh I'm actually going to
change my mind
um the only reason is because I took the
only reason I took the job was because
it's actually my dream job and uh but
the only thing I'm thinking about now is
that uh you know I still have you know
school there and some credit card debt
that I used uh for my Master's Degree
and you know now I'm trying to cash flow
writing so it kind of you know it was a
little concerning but I wanted to see
what
um you know that advice that you guys
could give
um was and you know that if staying in
the job is a good idea or you know just
moving forward will also be you know
another option that I have available I
guess yeah is your current situation job
wise is it are you still in it have you
quit that job is it a good environment
to be in all of that if you decided not
to take the new job
so yeah I'm really happy like uh it's a
it's a really high paying job I'm really
thankful
um it's just you know the opportunity
that I had you know to accept an offer
or well I did accept it
um for you know the dream job you know
it was really uh
um just the fact that it was my dream
job you know I just jumped at it yeah
without really thinking yeah
um I mean it you know you feel terrible
for the new employer but honestly for
you Dave I mean my priority is making
sure that you're that you're in a good
situation and since the current job you
have not the new and the current one
isn't bad it's not like you're leaving
because of a toxic work environment or
something a moral was happening
um then I would I mean I would humbly
say to the new job like hey I'm I know I
accepted this and I mean you didn't sign
any contracts or anything right on a
legal aspect with the new job
um no the only things that did make me
sign was uh the offer letter
um but it didn't there was no like
um obligation for me to you know come on
board by a certain date they haven't
given me a start date or anything I'm
still doing the whole pre-employment
process but there was no like obligation
for me to come on board and you know
sign my life away okay is this dream job
still going to be on the table two years
from now
um yes I guess another reason why I took
the job was because
um you know there's a lot more room for
growth later on and that's kind of like
where uh logically or one was one reason
why I took the job too because
um the differences and levels they they
do vary by a lot more here at the new
job that I'd be taking so what's the
what's this new job pay compared to the
current one
so my current job um I am making 110 a
year and then uh the new one is 94. okay
and how quickly can you move that 94
salary up since you said that there is
room to grow
um I'm guessing three years I also got a
sign on bonus I don't know if that that
kind of you know pushed me over how much
was it
uh 20K 20K okay here's here's what I'm
thinking what if we take this new job
since it's the dream job I assume you're
going to excel in it since it's the
dream you're going to grow faster than
you think what if you take on a side job
to cover the Gap so that you can
continue the debt snowball and once
you're there you've started increasing
your income your debt is gone now you
can easily continue in this job so
that's another option there instead of
back backing out of this whole thing
yeah yeah and especially since there's
room for growth Dave and you had that
twenty thousand dollar signing bonus
which is great because that kind of
fills in the gap for at least a year
right before that you're dead yeah and
uh continue to move up so I'm yeah I'm
good if you take the new job especially
since you know there's going to be a
growth track and maybe you talk to them
go back even and say hey I kind of
accepted this pretty quickly is there a
way to renegotiate maybe even my salary
uh to bump it up a few thousand dollars
just to help in the meantime it's got a
clear plan of what that growth looks
like yep absolutely thank you Dave good
luck and uh yeah have fun with the new
dream job this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
Proverbs 16 18. Pride goes before
destruction and a haughty Spirit comes
before a fall
Hmm this quote
from Derek Zoolander oh legendary
philosopher do you ever do you ever
think that maybe there's more to life
than being really really really really
really ridiculously good looking
that is one of my favorite quotes on the
show so far
I wonder if there is more to life and I
do often wonder that do you ever think I
was hoping you do the accent the
Zoolander accent what I know I can't do
it can you I can but I'm not gonna do it
do it George read it read it if I could
do it you can do it maybe there's more
to life than being really really
ridiculously good looking yes I don't
know something like that there you go I
know I know how much you love fashion
icons how much I love fashion icons
Zoolander is one man that was like a
that was a moment in our
you know you guys that it was like uh it
was a it was a staple it was a staple
like Napoleon Dynamite remember when
that was one too I know it was like a
brand it was your whole personality it
was like the office the office became
people's personalities yes they've
spoken office quotes oh so good good
times friends used to be that too
all right up next we have Titus in
Kansas City hey Titus welcome to the
show
hey uh thank you for having me on
absolutely how can we help
yeah so uh I just started a clothing
brand and it's really made me come to
the realization that like I need to get
my finances straight because I've I'm 17
and I've been working for like three
years and I have like no money and I've
tried to like budget but I just can
never like stick to it how's the
business going has it made money
um yeah I just launched like a couple
days ago but it's it's starting to pick
up and I'm making sales so it's working
out but I just want to make sure that I
can actually like sustain it and things
like that and I know that if I have bad
money habits it's just gonna all go down
the drain I'm not gonna know where I
went good for you Titus as an
entrepreneur you're a young entrepreneur
are you in high school still are you uh
working what's going on
oh yeah I'm a senior right now I'm
graduating in May okay are you planning
on going to college or trade school are
you going straight into entrepreneur
life
um I would love to just go into
entrepreneurial life but I may just take
some like business courses or something
like that for some networking
yeah I think that's wise to get some
education in that space uh to propel you
into this so with this business have you
gone into debt for it because you're
saying
you're wanting to follow the baby steps
where are you at financially do you have
money in the bank do you have debt
um so I'm not I don't have any debt and
but I just like I just I'm a heavy
spender so I I spend like all my money
basically when I get it and but I like I
have a good work ethic so I'll make
money and I'll have it coming in but
then I just kind of spend it even if
it's for something like Chloe and it's
like I always have like no money by the
end of the month you sound like me Titus
at 17. sound like a 17 year old three
checks Titus at Hollister when I was
your age can you guys picture little
racial Cruise running a check at
Hollister I did I did if you gave them a
check today they would be so confused
they were like what is this so Titus I
think you know you have a little bit of
that personality that if you I'm so
thankful you're addressing it now
because you you kind of have that
personality in that and that grit that
you could be one of those people that
just out earns their stupidity for a
while right you just make more money
make more money and I can still kind of
not be good good with money but I can
out earn my stupidity is what ends up
being
um and so you kind of have that a little
bit in you which isn't always bad
because that means if you can fix one
end of that equation and the other one
is flourishing of actually making money
and now earning you know or earning a
ton you're going to be in a great
position so I love that at 17 you're
self-aware enough to know this and start
working on it because you don't have the
life you know life in you know right now
in the sense of bills and having to be
in charge of food and grants and all of
that so Insurance that's right so I
would ask yourself Titus you know what's
causing you to spend one question I ask
myself because I know myself well is if
any if nobody sees this purchase do I
still want it
yeah yeah I've asked myself that
question too I think a lot of it is just
like like obviously just my interest is
like very like materialistic so I feel
like I just like spend a lot of money on
things but I definitely don't need but
like recently after I found your show
like I've just kind of been beat myself
up over it the past couple months and
like I just want to like get straight
and know that I'm like really making
progress so I can like really build
wealth I don't want to just be like
stupid with my hard-earned money though
yeah I think it's a great place to be
but now we got to move forward instead
of looking backwards being ourselves up
yeah don't beat yourself up ties you're
fine you're 17 man you're okay and you
said you don't have any debt right
no no dad at all yeah you're yeah it's
okay don't yeah so don't be hard on
yourself how much is the business making
like where's this income coming from
because you said you're spending it all
um so I work for an entrepreneur Academy
and I work about 30 hours a week and
then I also have another job at a
grocery store which I get things like
12 an hour uh and I get
um like I get like 15 hours
oh wow while in school full time I'm not
using that so yeah are you homeschooled
start the business
do you go to school are you homeschooled
um yeah I have like half like virtual
school and then half like regular school
so I'm able to work like extra hours
okay what a time to be alive yeah so I
just think I think for you Titus it's
it's just starting to put boundaries and
limits on your spending it doesn't mean
you can't spend anything but you want to
be very very diligent so I would remove
anything in your life that makes it easy
to spend and I don't know if that's apps
I don't know if that's your Amazon Prime
account and you need to log out of it uh
if it's the people you're around like
removing those obstacles of where you
just are tempted to spend or if it's a
place that you're like attempt you know
I go here right like the mall Hollister
that was that was the over that was that
was that was my my place to be at 17 and
and just to have the discipline right
now to say I'm not doing that and to
have a dollar amount that you want to
save every month status that again isn't
your whole paycheck because you want to
be able to give some of this money I
want you to practice being generous with
some of it and I want you to be able to
spend some of it but I also want a big
savings goal to look at and and start
that same you know drive that you have
towards these businesses make that a
drive towards your saving it's that same
kind of spirit to say I want to move
forward in this and be creative and
figure this out and that's what you want
to do with your money too and so hitting
that number is also a great way to to
goal set a realistic number and on the
business side you know the baby steps
don't apply to business in that sense
but what does apply is living completely
debt free running your business debt
free having a pile of money and savings
and your reserves to cover uh new
expense a new hire things coming down
the road an emergency and so there are
things that apply there I'm going to
gift you a few things number one is
Rachel's book know yourself know your
money because it's super important to
have that self-awareness of oh this is
why I am the way I am with money how do
I move forward knowing that so I'm going
to gift you that book as well as Dave's
book entree leadership this is how he
built this business from a card table in
his living room to the Empire it is
today and I'm gonna throw in one more
that could be helpful for you our friend
Christy Wright wrote a book called
business Boutique that really helps
those super small business owners from
this is a hobby this is an idea now how
do I actually jump into the marketing
how do I price this really well so that
it can grow and flourish so I'm going to
send you all three of those and and as
you grow this business let us know how
it's going I'm inspired by a 17 year old
who's like yeah I'm gonna do it my way
and own this and I would say two Titus
at your age at 17 I think one of the
best ways to use your time and your
energy and well is just is is investing
in yourself meaning like just learn from
this you know this this is a great
business you don't have to you know
don't make it like a this may not be the
thing that you take forever right but
you're going to learn a lot of lessons
in it which I think is great
um but the money that's coming off of
the business is what's amazing that
you're gonna be able to use that because
you have a transition coming up at 18
years old depending on where you go and
what you do that can be very expensive
so having some money set aside will
really really help you even if it's with
tuition if you're going to do you know
even Community College
um anything that's going to be able to
help and then on the on the other side
even through college still continue to
practice that saving because that that's
another big transition yeah into life so
I wouldn't I wouldn't ring your hands
don't be freaking out you're okay you're
doing great and just getting those money
habits that's the best investment you
can make on yourself absolutely hang
online Jen is going to give you those
three books we're going to ship them to
you wishing you the best man absolutely
George great hour thanks for co-hosting
thanks to everyone in the booth and the
show run thank you America for listening
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsey Show Channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]